في كل مره حاولت فيها القيام بذلك بخصوصيه
كانت هناك ايحاطات وتسريبات وخلق قصص ضد
زوجتي دراما ملكيه بامتياز بدات قبل سنوات
بطلاها الامير البريطاني هاري وزوجته
الامريكيه ميغان هرب من قفص الملكيه بحث
عن حريه الدعيان انهما سلبيا اياها
ورغبه منهما بالابتعاد عن الاضواء
الا ان ظهور الثنائي
بات اكثر مما كان عليه عندما كان تحت سقف
في قصر باكينغهام احدها كان مع برنامج
او برفقه كانت تدور معظمها حول كواليس
حياتهما السابقه
بتصريحات الناريه عزازه الفجوه بينهما
وبين العائله الملكيه البريطانيه التي
يزعم هاري بانهم استخدم وسائل الاعلام
ضدهما
المثير للسخريه هنا هو طرح مذكرات الامير
هاري للبيع قبل الموعد الرسمي لنشرها
مذكرات تضمنت مزاعم جديده عن الخلاف
والشقاق داخل العائله الملكه البريطانيه
واتهامات وجهها الامير هاري لشقيقه ولي
العهد البريطاني واليمن بالتعدي الجسدي
عليه حسب ما نقلته صحيفه عن تسريبات
الكتاب التي تقول ان الامير واليمن امير
ويلز وريث العرش وشقيقه هاري الاكبر اوقع
اخاه ارضا في شجار
كما ان هاري زعم ايضا ان شقيقه وليم تطاول
لفظيا على ميجا واصفا اياها بالصعبه
والوقحاء والمزيفه
الشهره التي اكتسبها هاري وميغن منذ ان
تخليا عن واجباتهما الملكيه في عام 2020
بدات ترتد عليهما بالعكس حسب استطلاعات
للراي فالكثير من البريطانيين ذاقوا ذرعا
بملو دراما العائله المالكيه برمتها وان
الكشف عن مزيد من المفاجات لن يغير ارائهم
سواء متعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته ميجان ماركل
او تلك المنتقدتها لهما
روان حمزه العربيه